it's July 13 2023 we're here in physics
as information processing with the third
lecture by Chris Fields so please check
out the course website Coda document
where you can submit questions check out
the recordings and descriptions of all
sessions and register if you want to
participate in one of the discussion
sections so thank you again Chris to you
oh thank you and welcome to physics as
information processing session three
which is about Quantum reference frames
so in this course we've talked about
Quantum information Theory
which we characterized as a general
theory that describes the exchange of
information in exchange of finite
information
um between two finite agents that are
separated by some boundary
and we've emphasize that this is a
topological Theory not a geometric
Theory so it makes no assumptions about
an embedding space-time
and last time I'll we showed how to
characterize this boundary of script B
as an array of in
some finite and Quantum bits or qubits
and how to characterize the interaction
of the agents A and B
with the boundary
as an alternating cycle of of preparing
and measuring these this the qubits in
this array
and we showed that their interaction
could be represented as a sum of
operators Each of which act on just one
of the qubits
and we also talked about
the need for each of the agents A and B
to choose a reference frame for their
interaction with the qubits that defined
uh which way was up
so what the orientations of the qubits
meant
and emphasize that the two Observers
uh A and B could choose different
reference frames so different ways of
measuring and preparing their qubits
that use different meanings for the idea
of up
uh for each qubit
and we ended the last session with a
pointer forward toward the quantum
formulation of the free energy principle
which can be stated as the claim that
interacting systems behave in a way that
aligns their reference frames
and I'll point it out at that time
that what this means is that the two
agents A and B approach entanglement
asymptotically and that therefore the
fep is a classical limit of the
principle of unitarity
which is the core principle of quantum
theory so we'll see in this session why
this is true
so what we'll talk about today
is what reference frames are in general
how they make observations and actions
meaningful so how they give physics a
semantics
and then we'll talk about the free
energy principle
so what is a reference frame
the idea
that physics involves reference frames
goes back at least a Galileo
but was probably familiar well before
that just not formalized in the way that
Galileo formalized it
so the key idea can be thought of uh in
terms of motion
and you're all familiar for example with
riding a bicycle or driving a car
and seeing the world as if it's passing
by you at some velocity with some
velocity
and of course with respect to the world
you're passing by it with some velocity
and this idea that velocity is not
absolute but that's relative
to some Observer who measures it in some
reference frame
is the foundation for theories of
Relativity so
Galileo developed his theory of
relativity
which basically was just a way of
converting from classical velocities
measured by one Observer to classical
velocities measured by another Observer
uh that was moving with respect to the
first one
and this provided the foundation for
Einstein's theories of relativity
uh which modified Galileo's by adding
the concept that The Observers have to
change exchange information
uh and can only exchange it at the speed
of light which is finite
so
this idea in physics has a long history
of course the core idea is that
measurements are always with respect to
something or other
and there's something rather is a
reference frame and different agents can
choose different reference frames
and this idea is very old here we have a
picture of Anubis uh choosing a feather
as the reference frame with which to rep
to to measure the heart of the Pharaoh
so this goes back to well before uh the
Common Era this is about
2000 BCE
so this is a very old idea that's been
elaborated
over the centuries as science has
developed
and in the 90s a fairly big change in
how this idea was thought about occurred
In classical physics reference frames
were always thought of as mathematical
abstractions
and an observer and a reference frame
were more or less identified by Galileo
and that identification is carried
forward into Einstein who thinks about
observers for example sitting on photons
and observers in spaceships and
observers riding on railroad trains and
this sort of thing and always that just
means think of a reference frame that's
doing something or other
so
I'll
a reference frame in classical physics
is essentially just
a coordinate system
and these abstract coordinate systems
can be employed in thought experiments
and so they are a way to illustrate
classical intuitions about motion
and in the 90s as Quantum information
theory developed
it was realized that
a reference frame actually consists of a
physical object I mean even in the
picture
from the Egyptian tomb the reference
frame is a physical feather
and that means that the reference frame
itself
is described by quantum theory it's some
Quantum system
and if you think about reference frames
that are familiar for example meter
sticks for measuring distance or clocks
for measuring time
or gyroscopes or batteries or even the
Earth's gravitational fields which
typically defines up for us
those are all physical objects that can
be described by quantum theory
well this was an important insight
of because it led to the realization
that reference frames as Quantum systems
are unique
and uniqueness in quantum theory is very
strong
um there's the no cloning theorem which
states that you can't reproduce exactly
reproduce any unknown Quantum state
and that applies to reference frames uh
because they encode what Bartlett at all
in that paper called non-fungible
information
which just means information that can't
be completely represented in any finite
bit strain
so unless you know the state of a
reference frame you can't clone it
uh since these reference frames
um
encode more than any bit strings worth
of information
in their Quantum phases
of
their unique and their states are
unknown
and the consequence of this is that if
Alice wants Bob to use her reference
frame to make a measurement
she can't just send him a description
she has to actually send the reference
right
and this has an important uh consequence
for physics
uh because it makes all replicate
measurements approximate
because observers obviously aren't using
exactly the same physical objects as
their reference frames
that there's a deeper implication of
this
which is that
Alice's ultimate Rock Bottom reference
frame is actually implemented by her
body by her brain
and using any external reference frame
requires having this internal reference
frame that makes the external reference
frame meaningful and usable so for
example
this thing is a piece of a meter stick a
third of a meter stick but for me to use
it to make measurements
I have to actually have some concept of
distance
and that concept of distance is
implemented by my nervous system
and that implementation is my reference
frame for length
and it's what gives meaning to any
external measurement of length it's what
makes my measurements of length
actionable by me using my effectors or
action capabilities whatever they are
so my internal reference frames are what
make information I get from the world
actionable
and in in bateson's sense of differences
that make a difference actionability is
the core of semantics something is
Meaningful if I can do something about
it
so this idea that we all
uh contain
embodied reference frames
gives physics as semantics by giving
observers or semantics and this is new
uh this is an idea that never really
appeared in physics before the
measurements automatically had to have
some kind of semantics
but reference frames uh give semantics
to measurements
so here's an example of an embodied
reference frame
this is the reference frame that
bacteria used for chemotaxis I.E to move
toward
molecules in the environment that they
like like sugars
and to move away from molecules that
they don't like like acids
and it's been worked out in great detail
over Decades of experimental work and
this is a rough schematic
of the reference frame has three parts
of there's the measurement part which is
conveniently located in the front of the
bacterium
and it consists of a bunch of receptors
that probe the environment
and they can bind molecules which are
called ligands out in the environment
and when they bind them they send a
signal into the back of the bacterium
and it turns out that there's a little
miniature reference frame attached
directly to these ligands which is this
R and B system which controls the like
the ligands the not the leggings the
receptor sensitivity
then the back of the reference frame is
the action component
and it consists of a set of molecules
that control a motor
a molecular motor that derives the
flagella on the bacteria
and the flagellum allows it to swim
forwards or turn in some other direction
and depending on how it spins uh the the
creature either goes in the direction of
something it likes or it stops and turns
around
and the stuff in the middle
is
a little molecular feedback loop
that represents the amount of ligand in
the environment that the bacterium
expects to see
so this is the middle of the reference
frame and it defines the default value
for what the bacterium is observing in
its environment
and if you're thinking in terms of the
free energy principle or Bayesian
inference then you'll immediately see
the concentration of this molecule is
encoding a prior probability
the bacterium's prior probability for
what its environment is like
and the zero point the default value of
that encoding is the ligand
concentration in which the bacterium
does nothing
so a qrf in general
can be characterized as an expected
value which is here the concentration of
this molecule
key y phosphorylated plus a bunch of
computation which is all the rest of the
things in this diagram
foreign
so this is a very simple qrf that's
embodied by a bacterium
here's a more complicated qrf
that's embodied by
eukaryotic cells who are more
complicated cells like our cells
and this is the reference frame
that makes decisions about whether cells
are going to divide
so on the top you see the cell's
membrane and there are all sorts of
receptors sticking out of it that detect
hormones and neurotransmitters and
growth factors and this that and the
other thing many of which are produced
by other cells
and those receptors
um communicate via a lot of chemistry
with uh the nucleus which is contained
in another
membrane
and so serves as in a sense the outside
upon which the reference frame is acting
and what this reference frame does is
control
the transcription of large numbers of
molecules from DNA so it basically
controls what proteins the cell is
making
and those proteins end up doing
something like restructuring the
cytoplasm and actually driving cell
division
and the stuff in the middle of this
reference frame
which I've labeled the integrative
Center
are three molecules called RAF Mech and
irk
and they're connected by positive by
bi-directional feedback loops
and they basically negotiate the default
value
of the environment at which the cell
does nothing
so they're the middle of the reference
frame
that represents the cell's expectation
values about what's going on in its
environment so you can imagine now what
reference frames encoded by our nervous
system look like they're extremely
complicated
and existed multiple scales from the
scale of molecules in cells to the scale
of large-scale connections between
parts of of our brains
so how do we represent all this stuff
uh there are many ways to do this
but this is a particular particularly
simple way
of it assumes that whatever's in the
middle which is here called C Prime
is
the most General thing that the inputs
can give information to
and the most General thing that can give
information to the outputs
and most General here has a category
theoretic definition
um so it could be
stated in a way that's equivalent across
many different uh specific mathematical
forms
but if you're familiar with neural
networks this will look to you a lot
like the skeleton of a variational
autoencoder
and that's basically what it is
and I don't want to deal with this
formalism except to say that it exists
and is very convenient
uh except to say that we can attach
this kind of formal diagram
as a representation of a qrf to our
representation of the boundary between
two interacting agents
and we can use these formal structures
uh to drive the measurement operators
that actually Implement physical changes
on this boundary
and I'll represent this whole business
with just a triangle labeled Q for some
qrf that's attached to the boundary
and we can use this simple notation then
to investigate what sorts of structures
one gets when one starts to think about
systems as implementing specific qrfs
and here's the structure of the minimal
system that we can really think of as an
interesting Observer
and this is a system that has some qrf
that I've called e
that looks at its environment the part
of its environment that it can actually
observe and act on
and it defines a sector of the boundary
how which mathematically is just the
image of this qrfe
that of the system can manipulate so
this is the part of the environment
or the part of the boundary that the
system actually seeps and can do
something about
and for this for this Observer to be
interesting
it needs to be able to detect the
difference between well it sees now
and what it saw just then
so that it can decide whether to take
some action or other
so it needs a memory
and that requires another qrf
that has some allocated piece of the
boundary recall the boundary is where
classical information gets written and
this purely Quantum theoretic formalism
so it needs a memory sector that that
qrf can act on
and then in order to do this computation
and specifically in order to write
information
to the boundary in order to actually
flip bits on the boundary
it needs free energy
so the rest of its boundary gets devoted
to
extracting free energy from the
environment and exhausting free energy
waste heat in other words into the
environment and so it has this nice
little thermodynamic cycle that drives
everything else
and finally
in order to tell now from just a second
ago this the information in memory
it needs a clock
that marks the information in memory as
not current so as past information
and if it can store multiple memory
records it needs to be able to count
and say this piece of remembered
information is actually more recent than
that piece over there
so it has to implement a little internal
clock and that clock is its internal
time qrf
and we've seen that qrfs act on
boundaries this clock acts on a boundary
but it doesn't act on B
it acts on an internal boundary
of
that's essentially the boundary between
it the clock and the points that the
ends of these qrfs that actually encode
information that's either read from the
environment or written to the
environment
so already this minimal Observer has a
little bit of hierarchical structure
which is that it's clock has to in some
sense be higher up in the hierarchy
then the parts the qrfs that interact
directly with the environment
so if you have a structure like this
you face a metabolic trade-off
for a fixed amount of of energy that you
can extract from the environment
you can allocate it either into learning
more about the environment
or remembering more about what you
learned before
and
so any system has to make this decision
about how they're going to use energy
are they going to devote it to learning
more or remembering more and your laptop
makes that decision memory is cheap for
your laptop
uh your brain makes that decision memory
is much more expensive for your brain
and all cells have to make that decision
and the universal solution to this uh
trade-off is course grading memory I.E
remembering things in less detail than
you saw them in the beginning uh Ander
you have a comment
uh yes uh I wanted to ask a question now
before it gets too late so two or three
slides ago
um when we were looking at the diagram
of the cone cocon diagrams I was
wondering if
um the
the classifiers identified with
measurement and preparation lows
correspond to sensory and action degrees
of freedom in the earlier picture with
bacteria and the
the classifier in the Middle with that
in that in that picture really
correspond to the default chemical
concentration that yes exactly
okay perfect yeah that uh
that crossing point in the middle is
specifically where the default is
encoded
thank you for pointing that out
okay
okay uh so let's follow the consequences
of this metabolic issue
of
if you have a system that's a little bit
smarter than our minimal system that can
actually detect and measure the states
of objects
it has to do even more work because it
has to encode even more qrfs
so think of measuring the state of some
object like a voltmeter in a laboratory
if I tell you to go into the lab and
tell me what the volt meter is reading
then the first thing you have to do is
find the voltmeter and your process of
finding the voltmeter is independent of
your process of reading what it's
actually saying on its dial
so in order to measure the state of an
object you have to have two qrfs one
that lets you find the object
and then the other that lets you measure
the state of interest of the object
and we call these the r sector for
reference that lets you find the object
in the P sector for pointer because old
old instruments used to have pointers on
dials that read analog numbers
foreign
but
what thinking about object
identification tells you is that every
object that you can identify
uh leads to having to sector both the
informative part of your boundary and
the memory part of your boundary into
two new sectors
one to store information about object
identification
and one to store information about the
states of those objects
so this requires much more metabolism
and again the solution is coarse green
and typically what would be coarse green
is our memory of the object that we've
identified
so what does this do to systems
um
because
making measurements costs energy
and recording memories costs energy
we have to make decisions about
what qrfs to use at what time given our
finite energy budgets we can't look at
the world with all of our measurement
capabilities at the same time because
it's too expensive
and now
uh
we see the effect of a theorem in
Quantum information Theory
which is that if two qrfs can't be
deployed simultaneously for whatever
reason
uh that corresponds to them not
commuting as operators
and if they don't commute as operators
they have to be implemented by
compartments that are sufferable so
compartments that only communicate
classically
the consequence of this theorem
is that as soon as
one has
too many
sensory and motor capabilities to run
all at the same time given your energy
budget
uh you end up being compartmentalized
into compartments that only communicate
classically so you end up looking like
this diagram
where there are a bunch of components
that do sensory motor Loops or memory
one or the other
and they can only communicate
classically
and they're controlled by some sort of
attention system
that selects which ones to activate
depending on the amount of free energy
that's available
and clearly this clock function
uh becomes part of this control system
so the physics alone
of any system that's acting as a fair
that executes a fairly complicated
interaction with its environment
gives us this hierarchical
compartmentalized structure
without having to add any
biological or cognitive science type
assumptions at all
so we could go in three directions from
this
uh we can go deeper into the biology
which we're going to do in October
we can go deeper into the physics which
we're going to do in August and
September
and we can go deeper into this issue of
alignment which is what we're going to
do today
so there are four possibilities if you
think about two agents that have qrfs
that are interacting with across this
boundary
and the first one is Trivial if the the
B agent the agent on the right side uh
doesn't actually employ any qrfs if it
just interacts with the boundary
thermally
uh then there is no alignment you're in
a trivial situation where a can measure
something about B but not in return
if the B agent deploys a qrf that's much
broader in scope than the a agent what
we show here in panel B
then the a agent can learn something
about the B agent but misses most of
what the B agent is doing
um in panel C we have agents with qrfs
of the same size on the boundary but
they're not lined up correctly so each
one misses part of what the other is
doing
and finally in D we have the optimal
situation where they have qrfs of the
same size
and they're actually lined up so each
sees what the other is doing at least on
this sector of the boundary
and since the agents have to to allocate
some of the boundary to free energy
Supply and can't look at that part
then they can't tell what's happening uh
across their entire boundaries they can
only tell what's happening in this
sector
uh where they can actually deploy a qrf
but let's now look at this interesting
uh situation situation d
uh where the qrfs are a large between a
and b
as I said that's the optimal channel for
a and b
and if we think about this we can write
the variational free energy or the
uncertainty or the prediction error
of
4A
for the qrfx
as
the action that it sees
I.E
B's action
the difference between that and what it
expects beta2
so what it can predict about these
actions
and this is just of the notion of free
energy
uh from the free energy principle except
translated into
um
the situation where we have two qrfs and
uh
a can measure what's B has done but it
can also use its qrf to predict
oh because it's predicting the very
state that it's going to observe next of
the same sector that b is using
now if we look at this diagram uh we can
see easily
that the way to minimize the variational
free energy
and therefore maximize predictive
capability
is for these two qrfs to actually be the
same
so if a
is doing
the same thing to the boundary that b is
a can predict these next action
perfectly because it's B is going to do
whatever a is doing
so
what the free energy principle tells us
in this case
is that a and b
as they minimize their variational free
Energies
will approach having identical qrfs
well again we have a theorem that tells
us that if these qrfs are shared A and B
are not separable but entangled
and this is this is also fairly easy to
see because it depends on this notion of
non-fungibility
uh if if x a and x b both encode
non-fungible information which is
quantum systems they do
oh their states aren't clonable
so they can't be copies of being sugar
because one can't clone an unknown
system
so they can only be identical if they're
actually identical systems oh this is
exactly the same point made earlier
about Alice having to actually send her
qrf to Bob if she wants Bob to use her
qrf
so
minimizing vfe
or Quantum systems is becoming entangled
so the classical free energy principle
which tells us to minimize vfa actually
drives Quantum systems toward
entanglement
and that's why it's a special case of
the principle of unitarity
which just says that any isolated joint
system is going to asymptotically
approach entanglement
so this raises an obvious question which
is why all of us aren't entangled with
our environments all the time
uh and entangled with each other
and the answer is that entanglement is
really hard for complex systems
and this illustrates uh the the sense in
which the fep is Moving Systems in two
different directions at once
the fep is Driving Systems to maintain
their separability
but it's also Driving Systems toward
entanglement
and as the system becomes more and more
complex the difference between those out
two outcomes becomes larger and larger
so recall from last time
that the condition for separability
is that the two systems have Dimensions
that are much larger than the dimension
of their boundary
and this is the condition that allows
them to have internal states to have
them have states that aren't located on
their boundaries
and clearly to formulate the free energy
principle uh you have to have internal
States
so if you're a complex qrf they're doing
a lot of computation
then you need a lot of internal degrees
of freedom to implement their
computation
saving a lot of internal state so you
have to have large dimensions
so complexity
favors separability as a system becomes
more complex it has to have more
internal States so it has to be in a
sense more separable from whatever it's
interacting with
now think about this classic one
if you have a complex system that's
doing a lot of computation
then it requires a lot of free energy
and it has to dissipate a lot of entropy
in the form of heat typically
uh
but something
some form of energy transfer that its
environment is going to see as noise as
not informative
so a complex system is working very hard
to predict its environment's next state
but by working very hard it's dumping a
lot of entropy into its environment
and putting in that extra entropy makes
the environments Behavior even harder to
predict so the more you work at
predicting what the environment is going
to do
the more you yourself make the
environment's behavior less predictable
and this is the the the Paradox of the
fep which is not really a paradox it's
just what the physics does
so we can think of the fep by Driving
Systems to increase their distinctness
from their environments or to
self-evidence as Carl friston calls it
um as uh driving this increased
complexity
that both makes predictions better
and makes predictions Harder by
transferring entropy into the
environment
so what this tells us is that the fep by
itself
will drive the development of systems
with larger and larger complexity
and this clearly has enormous
implications for evolutionary theory
which we'll talk about in October
um
but I want to emphasize here that this
is just the physics it's just what the
fep does when it's forced to maintain a
boundary
um
and before stopping here
I want to consider one of
aspect to this in particular
which is language for example human
language but any kind of language
connecting any systems that are
communicating with qrfs that are fairly
close
and language is a complex qrf
that we basically share otherwise things
like this interaction would be
impossible
but we also remain distinct systems
so the question arises how do we manage
to do this how do we manage to largely
share a qrf
all escaping becoming entangled
and this is a question that's largely
been ignored in physics because
physicists have tended to ignore
language
and just assume that observers can
communicate classically so for example
in talking about
a bell APR experiment which is a
canonical experiment for measuring
entanglement
The Observers have to be able to share
their results or they can't observe
entanglement right The Observer the The
observed result is
a bunch of observational statistics that
violate Bell's inequality and those
statistics can only be computed given
the results that both of The Observers
obtain so The Observers have to share
language to encode these results
so how come the observers aren't
entangled uh how come there are still
separable
what we end up appealing to is some sort
of common cause in the past to explain
why they share a language
they both learned it from their culture
so their culture is some sort of common
cause
but all such assumptions are fine-tuning
assumptions
so they all have basically
um the status
of
the value of something like the fine
structure constant without which
uh we wouldn't have atoms and so we
wouldn't have us
of this value has to be within very
small
limits of it of the value we actually
observe
and that's a case of fine-tuning the
universe seems fine-tuned in a way that
allows us to exist
and if it wasn't fine-tuned in that way
we wouldn't exist and so we wouldn't
observe anything
but fine-tending assumptions are a
problem they're a pointer to something
we don't understand
and so I just want to leave you with the
point that we have to be very careful
when talking about interacting Observers
so in talking about two components of
some system that jointly interact with
some environment
but also communicate classically and if
you think back a few slides that's
exactly the structure
that we've shown that the physics forces
any complicated system to have
so next time what we're going to focus
on is this very question
of how we describe Observers
that are both interacting with the
quantum system
and communicating classically in some
language
so that session will be in August at the
end of this month there's a discussion
of this session with Ander
and I encourage you all to
um
use the interactive q a to ask questions
you've been asking very good questions
that I hope I've been managing to answer
uh so thank you very much and Daniel
over to you
oh well we have a few minutes for some
questions so maybe
um and or if you want to
bring up any questions first
oh I mean then go for it
I was curious if you could say any words
on the slide where you had all the
possible alignment of qrfs and what you
meant more by interacting thermally so
when you have a trivial agent on one
side
what what exactly does it mean to to say
that your interacting thermally
um
if you think about a system that is only
interacting thermally with its
environment
um
you end up thinking classically about
for example an ideal gas that's in some
sort of container and some of the
molecules are very near the surface
uh and their emotions depend on the
Motions of all the other molecules that
are inside
so there's a a set of internal States
that interact randomly with the external
states that are near the boundary and so
those external States interact randomly
with the boundary
but notice in thinking in this way
uh you've imposed a space-time embedded
so you've actually used space as a way
of separating the internal States from
the boundary States
and a system that uh
if you drop this Assumption of this of a
spatial boundary
then a system that's only interacting
thermally with its environment
is going to look like a system that
doesn't have any real internal States
it's going to look like a system that
just has boundary States
and so a pure thermal interaction is
going to start to look like entanglement
so we're actually only really interested
in systems that aren't interacting only
purely thermally with their environments
we're interested in systems that have
enough internal structure that they're
using that thermal energy to do
something internally
so to to give their internal Dynamics
some particular shape
so that their internal Dynamics is
um
actually Circle circling around some
well-defined attractor
that requires some energy to maintain
itself
yeah I'm continuing with that question
um I saw in the paper free energy
principle for Quantum systems that if
you're in that situation now when both
cures are non-trivial but but perhaps B
is larger than A's
local hidden variables
so I wonder if there is a way to to
relate those by taking the limit of
making a small and recover the thermal
interaction
presumably
um if you let a become small you should
recover that thermal interaction so to
speak right
yeah that's that's a very interesting
comment actually so if if you're a
system and all of your environments
variables are effectively hidden to you
oh then you can't do any information
processing because you don't have any
access to any of your system your
environment's variables
so yeah your your interaction can only
be thermal I think that's correct right
thank you
uh I guess yeah
let's just so we since we're in in this
in this topic and we don't have to
context switch in that way
um on the other hand you have noise
right in in one of those other
situations
um I can't recall which one I guess I
guess in the Reversed one right when
when when as qrf is larger than that of
B so it encompasses more of the boundary
decrease of Freedom those that are not
overlapping a perceives us noise is that
that's that's correct right
well yeah it will be looking at at uh
B's thermal sector B's free energy
sector right so
a may be interpreting in a sense what
it's doing is informative
and it and a may even be seeing what B
is doing is informative
oh but so so noise for B may be signal
for a
depending on on what how A's qrf is
structured
oh but
a is is seeing more information than b
is trying to send it
so it's it's essentially the the reverse
of the Hidden variable case
there are
um
variables
in the other system that aren't telling
you anything about what the other system
is actually doing
that that's very interesting in terms of
um reading too much or too little
between the lines connecting too many
dots or connecting not enough dots but
these challenges where noise for one
Quantum cognitive agent might be signal
for another and vice versa those are the
challenges that we want to address
because to have a physics that doesn't
recognize those situations is kind of
taking the view from nowhere or not
really addressing the complexity of a
cognitive engagement
yeah it's it's describing interactions
between
effectively systems that don't share the
same language
I have a question about the free energy
principle here
um
only in the last several years as the
quantum free energy principle
relationship come into light so maybe
could you just share a little bit about
what incremental or Quantum advances
enable that to happen or what degrees of
freedom were pre-existing or added to
enable work arising from perception and
action in neural systems
to also so naturally
enter this context with the quantum
information
well I I think the at least from
a historical point of view
uh that connection was made based on the
analogy between a Markov blanket and a
holographic screen
so these are structures developed in
different parts of of physics that
essentially serve the same function
of limiting the information that one
system can have about another system
so uh it's that
functional analogy between a Markov
blanket defined classically
and a holographic screen defined in
quantum theory
that uh
made it seem obvious that we could
translate the free energy principle into
a Quantum theoretic principle
yes in live stream 40 we we talked a lot
about this but I think that
remains one of the most remarkable
advances inside or outside the free
energy principle literature
based upon this functional
acknowledgment of boundaries
and the conditions that they entail
which again are the challenges that we
want to address
lest we ignore boundaries
right yeah precisely I mean the free
energy principle is all about
what happens when you have a boundary
the waste Heats
is this
the actual thermal exhaust from our CPU
or how can we think about the Heat
being released
topologically rather than geometrically
like the location where it's released
what does it mean to consider
physical processes topologically that we
might otherwise just use a geometric way
of thinking about
oh well
you basically put your finger on it and
that you don't you're you're not worried
about the spatial difference between
uh
the geometric spatial difference between
oh
where one kind of information flows
through the boundary and where another
kind of information flows through the
boundary
uh and you can think about this in bar
called blanket terms
uh in the Marco blanket is just a
network
and some of the the causal arrows
flowing through that blanket Network
are effectively transmitting noise
oh
and you can you can get in the same way
with respect to a holographic screen
if you're doing a certain amount of
information processing and this this
brings up the whole issue of
oh how how efficient is a system
in
its information processing how close is
it to the the land hour limit basically
oh
can it
extract
more more uh energy
from some bits
than it has to use to modify the states
of other bits
oh that's what this this
if you will metabolic question is all
about
uh in the case of an organism is it can
I get more
energy from some of the chemistry that I
have access to
then I need to use to modify
the chemistry that I need to modify
and if not then life stops right
everything grinds to a halt
now can the heat exhaust
informationally be useful for another
agent somehow I mean can't we recover
heat in a steam engine and use it to do
useful work not to the point of a
perpetual motion machine but how can we
recover exhaust and then what does the
perpetual motion machine look like
well the the environment is the system
sitting over on the other side of the
boundary
that is uh absorbing
whatever waste heat is generated by the
system
let's call it Alice that we're
interested in
so that environment of maybe
and and Alice can't tell this it may be
divided up into lots of different
compartments
some of which are basically sucking in
Alice's waste heat and doing something
with it
so this is really a question about
how is the environment structured
and what uh
operations does the environment execute
with the input that it gets how does it
interpret that input
and what would uh let's get back to the
this gets back to this question about uh
how do we talk about multiple agents
that are communicating with each other
right instead of talking about uh
and environment that we don't
characterize at all
how do we talk about an environment that
includes some
specified or preferred systems that are
treated as or known to be other agents
so so uh let me get back to your
question about perpetual motion machine
uh notice that In classical
thermodynamics there's always the
assumption that there's a big
environment out there
you know the rest of the universe or
whatever the the whole environment
that's not on Earth
that is an arbitrarily large
source of or it's not an arbitrarily
large source of free energy but it's a
large source of free energy
and it's a large sink for entropy it
kind of arbitrarily large sink for
entropy
so the second law of Thermodynamics says
the entropy of this entire system
counting uh the the whole surrounding
environment doesn't decrease
so it can increase
and and still satisfy the second law so
this gives you the the classical you
know 19th century heat death of the
universe idea
and so you're you're a proposed machine
is
sitting somewhere embedded in this
gigantic environment
that can provide some finite amount of
free energy but can exhaust effectively
an arbitrary amount of entropy
so any any machine has to dissipate
entropy as it runs to to fill up this
kind of arbitrary
sync of entropy that's the classical
rest of the universe now compare that to
the picture in quantum theory
right the picture in quantum theory is
the universe by definition is an
isolated system
so it's total information content
doesn't change
right it's evolving unitarily
unitary operations preserve information
so they're just moving information
around
so from any uh
from the point of view of any local
system
the local systems getting information
from its environment so it sees its
environment losing information so
gaining entropy
what this tells us is that that entropy
is in fact not a
um
a globally definable quantity entropy is
always defined relative to some Observer
some division some boundary
and this is this is another
kind of big change in the last few
decades and has led to
for example in Tropic definitions of
time
now my local
external time Arrow
is whatever Direction I see entropy
increasing the most
so again I would refer to people like
Rovelli
uh and Max Tegmark who developed many of
these ideas
awesome
all right
thank you Chris and under
looking forward to seeing everyone's
questions submitted and their
preparation and participation and
measurements in the discussion section
so thank you until next time all right
thanks again Daniel uh thank you under
uh we'll see you later bye